[Musique]
de la fumée s'échappe d'édifices
détruits en plein cœur de Taipei pendant
que des civils courent aux abris
les exercices de réponse des services
d'urgence inclut encore cette année un
volet sur une attaque possible de
l'armée chinoise
militaires et civiles de toutes sortes
affirment le maire de tapis c'est le but
de l'exercice
ces entraînements ont commencé le mois
dernier et se poursuivront un peu
partout à Taïwan cet été
dans le cadre de ces exercices annuels
l'armée taïwanaise simule aussi une
attaque chinoise après la portion
virtuelle de cette semaine il y aura des
manoeuvres sur le terrain au mois de
juillet avec utilisation de vrais
munitions
pour la première fois les simulations
par ordinateur se font sur le même
logiciel qu'utilise les États-Unis et le
temps Taïwan teste donc ses capacités de
communication avec ses alliés potentiels
la sécurité dans le détroit de Taïwan
attire encore plus l'attention depuis
les récentes manœuvres chinoises en
réaction à la visite de la présidente en
Californie
nombre de médias et analystes
occidentaux qualifient la situation
d'extrême tension cette analyse rappelle
cependant que les exercices chinois ont
été moins importants que ceux de l'an
passé lors de la visite à Taïwan de
Nancy Pelosi l'ancienne président de la
Chambre des représentants américains la
rencontre a aussi eu lieu aux États-Unis
cette fois-ci et non à Taïwan ensuite
la Chine est Taïwan ont quelque peu
adouci leur ton dernièrement pour
favoriser les échanges commerciaux
commerciales et de maintenir un climat
favorable la situation pourrait demeurer
légèrement moins tendu jusqu'à l'an
prochain la principale raison étant la
tenue d'élection présidentielle à Taïwan
en janvier les deux principaux partis
politiques de Taïwan veulent se montrer
responsable face à la Chine et la Chine
espère l'élection du KMT partie plus
favorable à la coopération
même si la perspective d'une guerre
imminente et minime les risques de
dérapage imprévus demeure présents ici
Philippe Leblanc Radio-Canada taip